- I almost think that that's why
I'm so successful out there.
It's 'cause I'm only inside.
And for me, there is no winning,
there is no smelling roses.
One of the things I challenge myself
is to get a little bit
better at smelling roses.
But I'm not even sure that's right,
because I think the process is the rose.
You know, just playing is what I'm up to.
I just wanna play.
(upbeat music)
- You got your perspective.
(crowd cheering)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat pop music)
- Can you tell us something
really down to earth about you?
- Well it's funny, even the nature
of the question makes me uncomfortable.
(laughing)
So the meta of the question is probably
the most down to earth thing about me.
Meaning, I, it's actually
what I think a lot about.
My favorite thing is what people
who actually have met
me say behind my back.
That's the real answer.
I mean, the most down to
earth thing about me is
my parents and my circumstance
created a framework
where I'm unable to hear the cheering.
You know, and so I think one
of the reasons I deal well
with negative feedback is because
of the way I deal with positive feedback.
I think the reason so many
people struggle with trolls
or negative comments or judgment
is because they also
overvalue compliments.
So, for me, I think it's that I have both
of my index fingers in my ears.
(laughs)
What I mean by that is I
just don't hear either.
And so for me humility is the thing
I'm most attracted to
within myself and in others.
And so, yeah, just being
uncomfortable with the question
I think is the most down
to earth thing about me.
- Yeah (laughs), I love that so much.
I think in every, of all the content,
I mean, what I try to do with each guest
is research everything I can about them.
There is way-
- There's a lot.
- Too much content on the
internet, too, about everything.
- Yes.
- But your humility and even calling,
you know, the latest wine company Empathy.
- Yes.
That alone is something
that shines through
so strongly that you have.
- Thank you.
You know, come from what you call typical
immigrant upbringing and I love
that it stuck with you the whole time.
- Yeah me too, me too.
I think one of the things
I most struggle with.
You know, I think fame and money
and awareness exposes people.
I don't think it really changes people.
And I think it really
is sad to me to watch
contemporaries or friends or acquaintances
when they do hit a little bit
more awareness or more money
that there is an evolution
in their personality.
And I think that, I don't
think that's a change,
I think that's who they
actually were the whole time.
- Yeah.
- So, yeah, I'm very grateful
that I don't have that DNA trait
that makes me think I'm somebody
just because I may have some financial
or large following success.
- Yeah, well, what also is in your DNA
is this entrepreneurial trait
and this incredible ability
to be ahead of the curve
and to see, have this
intuition that lets you see
what other people don't, you know?
What the next five, 10
years are gonna look like.
- Yes.
- So in terms of your way
to yay, that's pretty much
the story of you got to a
life that makes you yay.
Take us back to the very beginning
because I think that
anyone who's looking to you
for guidance of how to
find what lights you up
and our lives, we're expected to have
so many different careers
in our lifetime now.
It's so overwhelming.
Take us back to young Gary.
Like, born in the Soviet Union.
- Born in the Soviet
Union, moved to Queens
for a couple years then
moved to New Jersey.
Um, very close to his mom,
Dad's working every minute.
Doesn't really have him in
his life the first 15 years
'cause he just worked so hard.
14 years.
And then I started working
at my dad's liquor stores
so I got to really know him.
But just quickly gravitated
towards business.
You know, six, seven, eight years old.
Lemonade stand, shoveling
snow, washing people cars.
- Baseball cards.
- Baseball cards, you
know all those things
and so much like somebody
is a natural athlete
or a natural singer-songwriter.
You know, every time I
watch videos of young Lebron
or young Beyonce, I always
think man, I wish my mom,
I wish there was recordings
of me at baseball card shows
or behind the lemonade
stand at eight years old.
There was a natural talent
that I had in selling
and so, yes, I, you
know it's so interesting
to be in the prime of my life
during the rise of entrepreneurship.
- You know, it's on a
pedestal, it's cool now.
You know, it's crazy for me because
when I was selling stuff in high school,
it was dorky, it was nerdy, it was like-
- Yeah, was it weird?
- Making money was not
cool, it was being good
at school or being good at sports.
So, it's very weird,
it's very weird for me
to have admiration or
recognize that rappers
and athletes and actors
and actresses all wanna
be entrepreneurs now and so it's very cool
in a lot of ways but I also have concerns
about people forcing themselves
into entrepreneurship
when I know that it's really
lonely, it's really difficult
and it's just not for everybody.
- Yeah, well I love, you
know, I was listening to
I think it was two years
ago you were on Joe Rogan
and one of the things you
pinpointed about yourself
that makes your DNA,
entrepreneurial to your DNA
not just in aspiration
is that six year old Gary
had Gary's Lemonade
Stand, had multiple venues
and you weren't just a kid
who wanted to sell stuff.
You were looking more at
where you would put the sign
to get the most sales funneled
towards the lemonade stand.
I don't even know how a six year old
could conceive of those ideas.
- It took me 30 years to even know that.
I was giving a speech and I just kinda
was giving my same
standard first five minutes
of my speech and I just
remember it very clear.
I just stopped, I'm like, wait a minute,
I used to sit, I mean how, I
mean this is just like, weird.
I used to sit and watch
these cars drive by
and literally take my sign and move it.
Drock's in the background
right now filming some stuff
and he got to see me in
action this last week
in Chicago at a baseball card show.
It's the first time I
was a dealer in 25 years
and I mean, the way I was
moving around the tables
and changing stuff and changing
prices and signs and angles.
You know, that's what I did and that's
what I do in content
and on these platforms.
The way I think about
LinkedIn and Facebook
and Twitter and YouTube and my podcast
and email service and
text messaging platform.
It's a lot of the same thing.
It's attention hacking,
it's attention arbitrage.
And it's not only attention.
Hey, here's the best part of my table
or hey, here's Instagram.
It's also what am I gonna say.
What's the language in the sign,
what's the copy I'm gonna put,
what's the title of the meme.
It is something I've always done.
- Yeah, it's cool watching your story,
how it literally just
from strength to strength
evolved through from six, from
your first business at six
to everything that you've since touched.
So, you moved into the
family business at 14.
- Yes, yes.
- Discount Liquors.
- Yes.
- Did a little rebrand.
- And it became the Wine Library.
- Yes.
- So a deep love for wine and sales and--
- Collecting.
- And collecting.
- Very big theme of my
life, collecting wine
was a huge reason I fell in love with it
because I was transitioning
off collecting cards.
- Baseball cards, yeah.
- It was a big, big,
big, theme of my life.
- And I mean, you turned that business
into e-commerce before
e-commerce was like a word.
How did you do that.
I mean, how do you
firstly upskill without.
I mean, you went to college,
you went through school
but how do you upskill to knowing
before there's a Gary Vee.
I mean, who was your Gary Vee, firtsly.
At your age was there a you who was-
- No.
- Prolific in content.
- And democratizing.
- Let me rephrase, I'm sure.
I mean, actually somebody who I'm very
fond of historically is Barbara Walters.
I thought Barbara Walters
was an incredible journalist
and incredibly smart
about culture and people.
But I didn't look up to business people.
Leveling up did not happen in school.
It came in the trenches, in the dirt.
And the internet, I had
probably been on a computer,
on a computer for less
than two hours in my life
when I decided to launch winelibrary.com.
- Oh my god, I mean, YouTube
had been like four months.
- No, YouTube didn't come out
until ten years after that.
- Oh my gosh!
- Wine Library TV.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Was four months after YouTube.
This is 1996, ten years before YouTube
came out, nine and a half.
I just inherently understand people.
Like, deeply.
Same reason I knew that VR wasn't
gonna be big in a year or two.
Two years ago when everybody
was going on that bandwagon.
I would, I look, I watch.
I'm watching what your fiance's wearing.
Like that, I literally, that's what I do.
[Man] How am I doing?
You look great.
I look at the haircut he's wearing,
I look at like everything,
I watch, I watch.
I'm an anthropologist.
I think if my DNA was
slightly to the left or right
I'd be one of those people
that goes into the Amazon
and for 29 years of their career
follows red headed ants in the Amazon.
I'm that curious by behavior.
Luckily for me, well not
luckily, for me the way
that's manifested is in
people and then trends
and behaviors around business.
But that maps to how we
look at social issues,
politics, which diseases or issue.
Like, why are we passionate right now
about plastic straws to paper straws.
I'm fascinated by why
that's the issue we decide
while textiles continue to
do enormous damage to Earth
and we've got people who are yelling
about the environment wearing Gucci belts.
I'm fascinated by that.
What you choose to do,
what you choose not to do.
You know, why coffee over
tea in our culture today.
Just those kind, I'm always thinking
but most of all, and this
is where humility comes in,
and I'm gonna round this up.
I never think I get to pick.
I never get to impose.
I don't think I get to
say what it should be
and I think a lot of
people think that way.
I watch and just react
to what people are doing.
- I love that you just ask the questions
that kind of give us the answers
rather than just hammering
answers down our throat.
You invite conversation
and you use your platforms
to really get us to think about.
I'm an anthropology nerd as well.
I did Law Arts but I did
all my theses on like
studying what people
do and why they do it.
It's why I find like war history and USSR-
- Yes.
All that stuff is so interesting.
- It's huge to me right,
like I leave a place
of communism, I go to
a place of capitalism.
You know, I'm also driven by gratitude.
I genuinely think if me
and my grandfather's,
both of them for that
matter, switched spots,
I'm the one who spends 10
years in a communist jail,
they're the ones who get
accolades in the current world.
So, you know, I'm driven by gratitude.
Like, just completely and
utterly driven by gratitude.
- Yeah.
I was adopted from an
orphanage in South Korea.
Same thing, came here I
was like it could have been
so different which means every
second is like make the most
of every opportunity
that there is out there.
- 100%.
- To use platforms to share these stories.
- Adversity at a young age
is an incredible foundation
of success.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- You know, you and I had
to live our whole lives
once it started becoming aware to us
what our circumstance was
understanding like, thank god.
No matter what was hard, no
matter if it was hard being,
for me, in a family that
was trying to make it's way
and it was a struggle early on
or for you, having to think
about like the dynamics
of being adopted or, no
matter how hard it was,
there was still a part
of your brain, mine,
that understood there
was an incredible luck
and great gift that
was given which creates
an really interesting
framework of just ambition,
you know, gratitude,
just a good mix of things
that tend to work out.
- Yeah.
So things have worked
out, some incredibly well
for you with that drive and intuition
from building the family
business I think it was
from three million to 60 million
through just taking it over.
Then founding media in 2011,
founding it with your brother.
You've got "Ask Gary Vee,"
you've got "The Daily Vee,"
you're like literally the
most prolific content creator
in the world which is
absolutely incredible
because you use it to inspire
the future generations
to think about what they're doing
and not just be on this
conveyor belt of achievement
which is what "Seize
The Yay" is all about.
Instead of seizing the day all the time
you've gotta find your joy
and do what matters to you.
- I'm on an incredible
mission, an incredible mission,
to redefine the north star
from financial success
to a happiness conversation.
- Yes.
- I really believe it can be achieved.
I'm flabbergasted by what has transpired
over the last three
years in watching a lot
of young alpha males
convert in front of my eyes from guys
that would do cliché, dumb
shit in their twenties
with girls and money to ones who talk
about empathy and kindness and gratitude.
And it is not lost on me
that I am taking the gifts
that my mom and dad gave me and
I'm giving them to the world
and my happiness framework
and the way I treat people
is for some reason becoming cool
and I'm just gonna squeeze
the shit out of that
because it's leading to good.
- Yeah.
So how do you in that whole
anthropological discussion
of redefining success
from a financial metric
and an external validation--
- That's right.
- To an internal, yeah,
like fulfillment metric.
When did you click over?
To I'm successful or what
does that feel like for you.
And you know, imparting to you,
you've got two beautiful children
and they, I'm sure, have had
their own lemonade stands.
What is the metric of success
or feeling or definition
that you want to impart to them.
- Well A) it's for them not to feel
like they have to own a lemonade stand.
So she has no interest in, I'm always like
let's sell slime or this and that.
She's like no.
I'm like great, awesome, you do you.
Showing a little bit of
an ability to flip cards
so that's exciting for
me as you can imagine
but I want them to love their game
as much as I love mine and whether that is
being a professor in a college
which would be really ironic and funny
or you know, a sculptor in
Egypt, or a stay at home dad.
For me, as long as they're
on fire the way I am
then I've achieved my goal for them
and to be honest I don't even
that sentence was funny to me.
I don't even wanna impose a single thing
other than, you know, making
sure they're good human beings.
That matters to me and making
sure they're not entitled.
I have to be very careful of that
given the financial circumstances
they're growing up in.
That's really it, that's it.
As far as like when it clicked for me.
It clicked in a couple different ways.
I remember the first day literally.
Oh, god, I'm getting really
interesting goosebumps,
like, different kinds,
like inside, not outside.
I haven't talked about this day,
I got a little emotional just now.
The first day of my career.
That first day, that first day
that was like, I'm done with college.
I will never have to go
to fucking school again.
(laughing)
And I will never forget
that Monday morning
in the liquor store.
It was the great, it might still be
my favorite day of my life.
It was just like I knew
I was on the beginning
of the thing that I was meant to do.
Which is you know, be a
professional business man.
And so, that was amazing.
Literally that day I felt successful.
And then, you know,
honestly all the accolades
like building up the business,
making the smart investements
in Facebook, Twitter, all
of that stuff, Tumblr,
Vayner, becoming Gary Vee, quote unquote,
writing those books and speeches
and the millions of followers.
There's, I don't see
things like, in that way.
I'm aware like when I
did "Planet of the Apps"
with Gwyneth Paltrow,
will.i.am, and Jessica Alba
I was aware, on Apple's platform,
I was aware like oh, this is cool.
This is another level up for
me in positioning to them
but you said something
so incredibly profound.
I am so inside, I'm so inside.
I'm only an internal validation,
I'm not an external validation
which looks like a contradiction
to the way I roll 'cause I'm so out there.
I almost think that that's why
I'm so successful out there.
It's 'cause I'm only inside.
- Yeah.
- And for me, there is no winning.
There is no smelling roses.
One of the things I challenge myself
is to get a little bit
better at smelling roses.
But I'm not even sure that's right
because I think the process is the rose.
Just playing is what I'm
up to, I just wanna play.
So much so that I even like when I lose.
- That's the best sound bite I've ever had
because there's a whole
segment called "Play to Yay"
which is forcing every guest to stop
and pull their identity
away from their output
'cause we're human beings we're--
- Yep.
- not human doings and not be achieving,
not be successful and what
is the activity that you do
and some people are like
"damn, I have nothing.
I don't play for joy. I
literally just go after goals."
And that's, there's no rose smelling.
- Yeah.
Like, what is it all about
if you're not doing that.
- So for me that get emphasized
a little differently.
To me, all of it's playing.
- Yeah.
- And all of it's smelling roses.
- Which is what I love about you
because I think people do sometimes try
and get this fitting in the boxes,
it's very artificial distinction
between work and play.
If you are on fire for what you do,
it's all work and it's all play.
- Literally my favorite things to do are
going garage sale-ing,
buying stuff and flipping it.
Like I get, and I've said this often
and it is absolutely true and it just is.
I get a much bigger
high of buying something
for $8 at a garage sale and
selling it for 26 bucks on Ebay
than I do in landing a $5 million client.
It's not even close.
- Arbitrage, I mean, it's your thing.
- Arbitrage.
(laughing)
It's just buying and
selling gives me a high
that nothing else does and so.
- You also said something
really interesting recently
which kind of landed really
strongly for me was that
it's so important to always have a goal
that's not, followers, financial,
if you're always going after
that you can hit the top.
But for you, like with the New York Jets,
you're goal is to own that football team.
- That's right.
- But you were like, if I did it,
what would I have to aim for anymore?
Like it's scary to achieve the goals.
So you have to tie it to something
that will always be to aspire to,
otherwise you've hit it too
easily, like what's left?
- And I think that for
me that's a good point.
And I think another thing
that's interesting to me
is I think you need to have
a selfish and a selfless goal
and I think they need to
be as big as possible.
So I think one of the
things that makes me happy
is my goal professionally
to buy the New York Jets
and then to win Superbowls
should keep me busy
for 30, 40, 50 years
which is a nice long time.
My goal to be the most giving
entrepreneur of all time
is something that will
take me my whole life.
You know, and it's extremely selfless.
Like, I am extremely
proud and quite conscious,
not just subconscious now at this point
that I am going to impact a lot of people.
And it feels really good.
Admiration is a lot more exciting
than a couple extra zeros
in your bank account.
And so, yeah.
- And that's why I love
these platforms so much
because when you can show
the human side of people.
Everyone is just a person.
That you being just a person
but using the incredible impact you have
for the positive benefit of people
out there in society, it's so exciting.
Like, you have made me
so excited for humanity.
- I agree, I think a lot of
people are confused right now
and they see the negatives
in social and digital
and they're seeing people scale hate.
What they don't understand
is it scales everything.
And it's on us.
If you're so happy then
start putting happy
into the universe.
- Yeah.
- You know, right now, the
people that are the most unhappy
are the ones who are loudest
in their content on social.
Nobody tweets "Great job Qantas"
on the flight we just took.
A machine just went in
the air, landed safely,
I had a nice coffee, I had wifi,
I bought some sports cards,
I don't land and tweet
"Qantas, great job on my flight today."
But if it was a three hour delay
and they were out of coffee, the amount
of people that tweet, you
know, "Fuck you, Qantas."
You know, people are
unbelievably interesting to me.
We stay very, the 98% that are happy --
- They don't like to talk about it, yeah.
- Are staying quiet.
And the 2% that are miserable are loud
and it confuses the other 98%.
And I don't wanna do that.
(laughing)
Right?
- I think you can use a--
- [Man] I'm a complainer on Twitter
but I also make sure recently.
When we open a restaurant
everyone wants to complain.
Especially with the vegans.
- So now I'm really conscious
of always do the good news.
- And that's the thing I
tell a lot of my friends.
I'm like don't wait for you
to be on the other side of it.
Like, recognize what we're doing
and so for me, I'm
putting, you know, when I.
I think this morning on the way
to the shower I tweeted a blue heart.
That was it.
And like, and that's just nice.
- And the internet went wild!
- I mean, I don't know if they went wild
but I think one human seeing that
maybe just thought that's nice.
To me, we need to start doing that.
We need to make like,
maybe this is the podcast,
this is the moment.
Let's make a call to arms, like if you're
in a good mood, fucking share it.
Because this tiny percentage, and I mean.
Guys, the reason we are still
here all these years later
is human beings are remarkably good.
To remind everybody, we
have had atomic bombs
that can wipe us off the face
of the Earth now for 70 years.
We're here.
We've had genocides, Holocausts,
we've had the black plague,
we've had world wars, we're here.
And everyone--
- The human spirit is resilient.
- It's unstoppable and
everybody's dwelling right now
on a rise of nationalism
and hate which is terrible.
However, let's contextualize it.
And, instead of judging people
and calling them racists
or bad people, why don't
you go loud about good?
Instead of getting sucked
in to being doing more hate
around people who hate, why
don't you actually combat it.
Why don't we learn from Martin Luther King
and from Gandhi and from
other people in the past.
Which is you do not defeat
hate with hate on hate.
You defeat hate with love at scale.
And we all have our 14
followers, our 1,000 followers,
our eight followers and instead of flexing
about your new handbag
or your hot new sneakers
or the hike you took or the
remarkable meal you're having,
what about putting out good,
what about cosigning somebody
that did something nice?
What about watching somebody
open a door for an old lady
and roll up on them and make a video
and tell them about this nice kid.
We need to get louder about happiness.
If we all collectively do that,
I have a funny feeling the internet
will feel a lot more happy.
- Yeah, I mean that's what this is.
There's a little quote book
it's called "Seize the Yay"
like the podcast it's a
happy quote for every day.
- I love that.
- And people like
everywhere just I'm like,
life is pretty awesome, we're
in a really exciting time.
It's a great time to be
alive, be excited about it.
- 400 trillion to one.
- Yeah.
- 400 trillion to one, that
is the current scientific odds
around being a human being.
- And that's something that a--
- Did you know that, 400 trillion to one.
You were more likely to get struck
by lightning ten times in
your life than have one.
It is the great miracle.
Like that whole miracle concept,
like the baby's a miracle!
It's actually true.
It's actually true and so
people are walking around moping
about their mom being
a jerk or their brother
stealing their money or somebody, I mean--
- Or their pimple on their face.
- Or their pimple on their face
or they can't get a new supreme.
I mean, just or--
- The Gary Vee sneaker sold
out, it was like so fucked up.
- Or like stuff that, I don't know
why this specific thing drives me crazy.
People yelling at baristas
for using the wrong milk.
I mean that to me, I don't
know what it is about that one.
You know, people literally
yelling at somebody,
"No almond milk, you asshole!"
They just bought a $6 coffee,
do you know how blessed you are?
- (laughing) Yeah.
I mean, a $9 coffee, Gary, come on.
- Respect.
(laughing)
- So just to wrap up quickly.
- Yes.
- I want to give a little shout out
to one of our mutual friends Justin Dry
and the incredible work
that he's doing with Vino.
- Yes.
- Vinomofo.
- You are here to launch
Empathy Wines in Australia.
- Yes.
- Which is so, so exciting.
So just quickly give
us a run down on that.
- So I started a winery almost
a year ago called Empathy Wines.
The ambition is to produce
and incredible wine
in U.S. dollars, a $40 wine for 20 bucks.
Obviously there's some price
variations here in Australia.
Justin and I have been
friendly for a long time.
We only wanted to sell direct to consumer
from winery to people in America.
He reached out, we got
into a conversation.
There's such warm feelings
there and admiration.
We got into a convo and Vinomofo
is the exclusive partner
of being able to sell
the wine outside the U.S.
in the Australia, New
Zealand, and Singapore market.
And the response has been
remarkable in this marketplace.
- It's a beautiful rosé.
- Thank you.
- Californian grapes.
- And the white just came out and the red
will be coming out in the fall
and so it's been incredible
project and it's really.
You know, it's funny, when
I was making the rosé,
I was thinking about an Australian rosé.
There's an Australian
rosé that I'm very fond of
called Turkey Flat and I remember
as I was blending it,
the whole time I'm like,
I'm gonna make a better
rosé than Turkey Flat.
I'm gonna make a better rosé
than and Whispering Angel.
Those were the two things
I was thinking about.
And so, it's been a lot
of fun and the partnership
with Vinomofo has been extremely seamless
and completely built on
kindness and friendship
and empathy and I'm enjoying it.
- So exciting to see it go live tonight!
- Thank you, thank you.
- So excited, we'll be partying.
So two last questions.
- Yes.
- What are the three most
interesting things about you
that don't normally
come up in conversation
and you are probably the
hardest guest to come up
with anything that hasn't
been on a podcast before.
- I'm remarkable non
confrontational in real life,
even though I'm a tough
guy on video and stage.
- Nice.
- I sleep seven to eight hours a day.
- No.
- Yep, yep.
- Amazing.
- I mean six and five when I travel.
- It's possible!
- And.
I really don't, I genuinely don't care
if I'm financially successful.
Like, deeply.
Like almost to the point
where I have to be careful
'cause I almost can feel as I'm evolving
the want to sabotage myself.
(laughing)
I'm not kidding, I like
really have to be thoughtful.
I'm really having a very
interesting time with myself
where I'm like, man I really almost like
and I've said it a lot
which means it's like
I get into this weird
like am I gonna become
like a weird monk and just disappear?
I'm.
- Am I gonna go like.
- I'm just all about happiness.
And maybe my version of a weird monk
is actually to just become a
junk and baseball card dealer.
Right, like just really go there.
But I can feel it in me.
- You gonna Marie Kondo yourself.
- Maybe.
- That's next.
- Maybe, I'm just a very.
Things are very clear to me.
- I like that.
- And they have nothing to do
with the modern version of success.
This is not about stuff.
This is about waking up
and not having anxiety.
- I love that.
And final question to finish up.
- Yep.
- What's your favorite motivational quote?
- I don't know.
- It can be a Gary Vee
quote, that's also fine.
You can make it up on the spot.
- I will and I can tell
you like what I think about
which is kindness is karma, right?
Give more than you take and
probably wrapping it up,
probably my favorite thing to say
'cause it hits people once in a blue moon,
doing the right thing is
always the right thing.